allegations on multiple fronts
somebody is lying here now one could
carry
serious consequences i don't know why
they're so obsessed
uh about this issue and the prime
minister's already said that he's paid
uh 100 for the refurbishments of the
number 10 flat
that worked this morning but after
today's intervention it's not just the
prime minister with his head in his
hands
these investigations cast a long shadow
across westminster
that's because the law on donations and
making sure politicians comply with it
is fiendishly complicated
political parties elections and
referendums act 2000
and that polices everything to do with
political parties
politicians loans gifts of money
everything that
might affect you know an election and
mps
and ministers have to declare what they
receive
in order for people to be able to see if
there's any conflicts of interest
tony blair was the first to move into
the flat above number 11
in 1997 and all prime ministers and
their families
have been there ever since this
refurbishment was more controversial
than normal
because the cost was so large it
couldn't be footed by taxpayers
in february last year aids were first
made aware of escalating costs over the
renovation
by the spring tory donors understood to
include jcb
chief lord bamford were first approached
to pay for some of the costs
in june the cabinet office is believed
to have paid the entire bill
on the understanding that sums above 30
000 pounds will have to be reimbursed
the question was from where tory party
chiefs and number 10 officials
considered a trust which could have
retrospectively funded the work
and then in the summer of last year tory
hq reportedly paid the cabin office to
clear the debt
elite email revealed that in october
last year lord brownlow said that he had
paid 58
000 pounds for the soon-to-be-formed
downing street trust
it's unclear what came of this money and
does not appear in public registers
it's boris johnson's political
reputation at stake
but it's the people in here conservative
headquarters who actually face the fines
of up to twenty thousand pounds
and even the chance of a police referral
that's if they can't answer electoral
commission questions
about what happened to the fifty eight
thousand pounds apparently given
by a tory donor to sort out the costs of
the flat refurbishment
but with just over a week to go until
elections across
england scotland and wales is this
cutting through
in the prime minister's constituency
opinion is mixed
the budget if i may be wrong in this is
30 000 pounds to do um for the pile for
the prime minister to do up his
apartment
and um and i've heard he spent two
hundred thousand said um and lied about
it so that's not acceptable i think
there's bigger things in the world to
worry about
we've all thought about doing something
naughty once in a while
but he didn't do it so that's it if you
move into a flat with somebody else's
lived in you need to get it refurbished
through all the hue and cry today these
investigations take months and have
proved hard in the past to reach a
definitive conclusion
sam coate sky news